it's going to be a real scandal on the
highest order america's ever seen it
really is the first time i think the
internet is breaking a story of this
magnitude we can't talk about it much
further because we've got an fcc license
on the stations at air entertainment
tonight
there's serious problems of sexual
malfeasance in the in the white house
we've got everyone in washington now
aware of a story after i broke it over
the internet over the weekend
after newsweek stopped the story when
they decided not to run this story i had
an opportunity to move in and they
presented me that opportunity and that's
what i did and they're going to have to
live with that mistake in the history
books a possible pivotal night here at
the white house things are moving so
quickly in the exploding accusations
that president clinton lied and or
obstructed justice i had sources in and
out of government that were informing me
that tapes existed of a woman saying
i've had a year and a half affair with
bill clinton and she's in early 20s and
he asked me to
cover it up
he asked me to lie they offered me jobs
um
huge story i don't know much about her i
know she lived at the watergate
oddly enough so i'm calling this
watergate 1998. it's stand and deliver
time for the president and for special
prosecutor kenneth starr the president
led his own counter-offensive today he
said quote the allegations are false the
problem began when sworn testimony
started taking place in the paula jones
case
and when you start getting away from a
wag the dog
spin
political spin
into oaths
uh you're you have to operate in a
different realm there's other things
i've broken there may be a dna trail
this young woman was bragging
that she'd kept a garment
after a sexual episode with clinton
and she swears she'd never wash it
um if that garment does exist
this is a
this is a story that will turn
washington upside down but i want to say
one thing to the american people
i want you to listen to me i'm going to
say this again
i did not
have
sexual relations with that woman
miss lewinsky i'm taking on a media
establishment that
basically i think has not been honest
with the american people there's an
atmosphere in washington that is
it's simply
you don't report
embarrassing stuff
about a president unless you're 100 true
and i'm not sure that has to be the
level you reach at this time i think you
give it to the people they're not babies
and we could sift it through and we can
discern if these are serious uh
accusations i'm just one man who's
reporting what i see and what i hear
from the street where i live i think
what we're seeing now may just be the
beginning i think a hole has been
punched in the boat that and waters uh
water's filling up and all hell's broken
loose the allegations
are false
and i would never ask anybody
to do anything other than tell the truth
well the website has crashed i mean this
story is so hot uh it's crashing
websites all over the place i can't get
uh
it's brought my operation to a
standstill it's like the newspaper is
being sold out at the newsstand it
really is the first time i think the
internet is breaking a story of this
magnitude and leading the way the
allegations were made in the secretly
taped conversations of lewinsky who
first met the president as a 21 year old
white house intern she has been
subpoenaed to testify in the paula jones
sexual harassment case and she swore
under oath that she never had an affair
with mr clinton it's a chain reaction
that began with the paula jones case
when you attack the accuser and one
thing led to another paula jones led to
a white house staffer kathleen willi
kathleen willie led to lewinsky you
start when you become aggressive and
you're talking from the highest office
in the land you never know where that's
going to lead and honesty is the best
policy in this and it looks like they've
got themselves in such a mess
i don't know how they get out of it i
don't know how you put the toothpaste
back in the tube
we are going by the book
we want the truth we want all the truth
we want it completely accurately and we
will satisfy our
we will satisfy ourselves that we're
getting the truth and that is the
absolute
bedrock point we want the truth the
lewinsky case is far from over
if in fact she's indicted i think she
has not been totally forthright and this
is why investigators may or may not be
interested in her apparently behind the
scenes the activity is just breathtaking
and the investigators the big problem is
they don't have enough manpower
to chase down all the leads but again
it's a real
real dark hour i think for the country
this is not something i'm
reporting with with gusto and
a happy
happy face this is a sad story about
deception and fallen leaders
so no i don't feel vindicated saturday
mr clinton testified under oath a source
familiar with the deposition says mr
clinton acknowledged it was possible
lewinsky saw him at odd hours in the
white house but he said she was probably
delivering documents mr clinton denied
under oath any sexual relationship with
lewinsky if and when it dries up the
cameras will run away from the story
but you've got something there you've
got a president denying it you
apparently have a prosecutor that
seems to feel the other way that's the
classic combination
for intrigue and uh it's almost like a
a 1920s 1930s movie playing out in
washington and people all over the world
are interested at what point does it
really become a an issue beyond
someone's private life and someone not
able to govern i don't know
you know each citizen will make that
decision but it looks like we may have
to come face to face with this soon
downtown los angeles the lucky hat it's
been very lucky to me
so i'm superstitious that way it
represents to me a whole era
when uh people actually hit the streets
and people uh weren't so concerned
with the
what people thought of them since i run
my own website and i'm my own reporter
and i'm my own editor and my own
publisher and my own publicity person
it's a whole multi-faceted it's sort of
a new generation media where
you can operate a full-blown newsroom or
a magazine out of a computer
and um you know i've got a funny face to
match so that gets me on the tv skast is
the founder and publisher of the
internet's controversial drudge report
well who's telling more truth this
summer me or the president of the united
states and what the internet lets you do
is anyone
participate and if you've got something
to say and if you've got the hottest
scoop you can compete with the big boys
you know you hit the street with me and
maybe hitting the emails
or the chat rooms i've had the best
online conversations with white house
sources through america online chat
rooms you go on the internet in any of
these news groups and it's a it's like
the wild west revisit it but there is an
ongoing investigation
and i think it's important that i go
back and do the work for the american
people that i was hired to do president
uh refusing to explain what if any
relationship he had with the former
intern
and i seem to be in the middle of it the
lewinsky thing has been nothing if not
put my name on the map it was getting
hot going up to that but uh boy this
thing has just made it sonic well it you
know a couple years ago i was folding
t-shirts in a gift shop
so this whole thing is uh
you know it's it's kind of a media you
know fantasy
from uh you know from the very beginning
it felt like magic
i know that my public comments and my
silence about this matter
gave a false impression
i misled people
including even my wife oh i had almost
eight hundred thousand people into the
website yesterday those who think that
last night's speech
was the closing curtain i think have
uh i haven't even begin to see the third
fourth act of this thing indeed i did
have a relationship with miss lewinsky
that was not appropriate
in fact it was wrong but i told the
grand jury today
and i say to you now
that at no time did i ask anyone to lie
to hide or destroy evidence
or to take any other unlawful action the
key thing at this point since he's
conceded the relationship or somewhat is
the cover-up
is the chain of events surrounding
monica lewinsky and what exactly he may
have asked her to do and other people in
the white house he had problems with the
timeline of the case
that he was not
clear
on specific aspects of the case and he
did more himself more harm than he did
good now this matter is between me
the two people i love most my wife and
our daughter
and our god nothing is more important to
me
personally but it is
private
and i intend to reclaim my family life
for my family
it's nobody's business but ours
even presidents
have private lives i think if the white
house had to do it again
they would have kept him off that camera
and wouldn't wouldn't have testified
because quite frankly i think he's
gotten himself in a worse hole but the
president gave no indication that he
would ever have come forward if it were
not for the fact that he was subpoenaed
before the grand jury starr still sends
a report to congress mr clinton is
trying to get impeachment insurance with
his speech you know i've heard portions
of these tapes between michael wins and
linda tripp and
she's quite an entertaining lady herself
and i think she's got
a lot to say we can't talk about it much
further because we've got an fcc license
on the stations that are entertainment
tonight but what impact did his
televised address really have a cbs news
poll surveyed people who watched the
president's speech 62 said his statement
had no effect on their opinion of him 25
said they think worse of him while 11
think better of him that is what's
pushing this it's much more of a
spectacle than it is people looking up
to him as a leader
during a crisis potential
i don't think that's what they're seeing
in him i think they're seeing in him
much more of good good drama and soap
opera and j.r hewitt was the man we love
to hate
it's embarrassing little scene in it you
know this story started from my
apartment upstairs and i wish i could
have a nice clean ending to it so i can
take a summer vacation but i just don't
see it at this point
i suspect bill clinton may be one of the
best men do you think a president really
needs the support of hollywood
absolutely not
i think that was proven in the last
election
where you have very few people coming
out in support of the republicans period
let alone a presidential candidate so i
think that trend will continue you know
during the clinton years it was
fantastic it was hollywood and it was
royalty the bush years it's just kind of
boring
[Music]
you